My name is Derrick Winje.
I am the director of sneaker operations
at The Cobblers in Miami, Florida.
Today, we're gonna be sole-swapping
a original 1985 pair of Jordan Chicago 1s
with a donor sole.
And these actually released in 1985,
with a retail of just $65.
For reference, the same
pair in 1985 for $65
is now in the aftermarket, brand new,
for about $20,000,
and that's if you can even find a pair.
The first step that we need to do
is acquire a donor shoe.
In this case, the client
had provided a donor shoe,
which is actually the 2015 Retro,
which is merely just a
rerelease of the shoe.
On this particular pair,
the customer requested
that we leave the upper of the shoe,
which is all of the leather.
He did not want it cleaned.
He did not want it painted.
He didn't want any conditioners.
So we need to carefully take off the sole
without, you know, damaging the sole
or altering anything.
In this case, the upper of the donor shoe
is not as important,
but sometimes we use those
parts for other things.
So, what I like to start with
is just using heat and acetone.
Ideally, I'll pour the
acetone inside of the shoe
to actually loosen up the glue
that is on the footbed and
the sidewalls of the shoe
to kind of break that down
to give me an entry point in the side.
Once we're able to get to that layer
of stitching on the sidewalls,
we can then use an X-Acto knife,
as you see I'm using here,
or you can also use a seam
ripper to undo those stitches.
Once the sidewall and stitching is undone,
it should be pretty easy from there.
We can either just pull the upper apart
or continue using heat or the acetone
to break up that glue
to separate the sole from the upper here.
It's a similar process
to remove the original
upper from the sole,
if it's not already detached.
In this case, there is stitching here,
as you can see.
However, we don't want to use excess heat,
and we also definitely don't want to
pour acetone into the shoe,
as that would damage the
upper of the original.
On the sides here,
you'll see that I use a bone folder,
which is just bone from an animal.
It's just a -- not a sharp edge,
but a blunt enough edge that
I can open up the sidewalls
to get down into that stitching there.
Once the two pieces are
completely separated,
we're going to remove all of the dust
and crumbling inside of the original shoe,
as well as from the upper,
to prepare this upper of the original shoe
to be put on the donor shoe.
We use a contact cement.
It is made for shoes.
It is flexible. It's clear.
So it's perfect for what we're doing here.
And it's very important
with any type of restoration we do,
when we're working with glue,
especially in this case,
that we get a clean surface
and get that fully prepped
and all of the old glue,
any dust or any buildup, oil,
water that may have seeped into that shoe.
The reasoning for this is because
if we don't have a clean surface
for the glue to adhere to,
the glue is not gonna fully do its job
in holding that shoe together
for the longest period of time.
We will apply one thin layer
to the upper, in this case,
as well as on the sole of the donor shoe,
and we allow that to dry.
A tip that I like to use
is actually to let this glue overcure,
so it gives me more
time to fit the sneaker,
as opposed to having to put
it all together in one shot.
And this, again, is so we can line up
the upper properly on the sole,
so there's no distinction
between the original sole
and the donor sole being
lined up on this 1985.
Once we have heated up the glue
and pressed it with our hand
to make sure everything
is fitting properly,
we will then just double-check
and make sure everything is
lined up the way we like,
so everything looks original.
We'll then take the
original last from the shoe,
which is just the interior of the shoe,
if you can think of it
as what shoemakers use
to make and shape shoes.
We'll place that into the shoe,
and then we will take it
over to the bladder press.
What the bladder press is gonna do
is basically give us that extra security
and push the shoe together
and make sure that the
glue is fully bonded
and has a strong hold to it.
Once we're done, you can see here
that we actually stitch by hand.
There is a machine,
but with something this delicate
and this fragile and rare,
we actually prefer stitching it by hand,
just so we know that every stitch
is fit perfectly into the original hole
to make things look as
original as possible.
So, you can see, this isn't a
pure white thread we're using.
We actually have an aged
or more of a vanilla cream thread,
which is gonna match the
original look of that shoe.
If we were to put a bright,
brilliant white lace or thread in there,
it would kind of take
away from the originality
of keeping the upper a little distressed
and having the sole looking brand new
on top of an old, distressed 1985 shoe.
We actually add a little bit of wax here,
to imitate the original shoe upon release.
Now that everything's stitched up,
it may not be mind-blowing
before and after
just putting a sole onto a new shoe,
but to us, in these little details,
this makes the shoe complete,
and I think the customer is gonna be
very happy with these results.